crazy question for you to see what you
think about this
so um
1984 I think it is that we make
advertising uh can you look up when we
made advertising big Pharma legal in
America I think it's 84. and I think
Prozac came out in 88 87 if you can look
up when Prozac came out and when we made
it legal what year is it when we made it
legal is it a Google search that zoom in
you'll see it okay anyways while you're
doing that what do you think would
happen if
out of a couple hundred countries in the
world whatever the numbers 193 or 208
okay only two countries big Pharma gets
to advertise in those countries New
Zealand and America okay
what do you think about if a president
campaigned and said moving forward guess
what if your product is good they'll
find it no more advertising on media tv
YouTube social big Pharma not necessary
because it's a legalized drug dealers if
you're if your work is great if it's
doing phenomenal great I feel a little
bit uncomfortable that this person I'm
paying 15 million dollars a year 10
million dollars a year this much money
per year of course they're going to say
good things about the drug because I'm
getting the money let's not do that
moving forward what do you think about
us eliminating as a candidate would you
somebody who is on the you know maybe on
the left supportive or more on the
Democratic side would you say I actually
would entertain the idea of getting rid
of that well and and there's another
very good argument for getting rid of
drug advertising which is you know one
of the big issues 85 with with
um
with drugs at this you know
Pharmaceuticals at this point is how
much they cost I mean you know the fact
that people can't afford the medication
they need
in a world where there's advertising why
are we through Medicare or Medicaid or
through our insurance paying these drug
companies to advertise I mean that it's
not it's not that it's not that we're
learning it's not just that
um you we may be getting in you know
getting unnecessary prescriptions it's
that you're adding to the cost just by
um the the in the the cost of
advertising it's it's a it's a very
legitimate question you know one of the
things that uh and I can I I uh I
certainly knew this from my time at CNN
you know in an age when a lot of
formerly uh big advertisers don't
advertise anymore like for example I I
I'm going to take the liberty of saying
that all of you are old enough to
remember when Airlines used to advertise
on TV all the time oh big time they
don't advertise at all anymore you never
see a Delta add a a United had
um
if you turn on CNN if you turn on MSNBC
if you turn on Fox it's one Pharmacy
it's not just left or right it's
everybody well and also this has to do
with the fact that the news audience is
older exactly and I used to I used to
joke I mean this is sort of a dark joke
I love it about uh when I was at CNN
that you know that you know if you look
at the ads that our audience
is 100 dying uh because of what they
need like there was one ad that was used
to run all the time it's like
you take this drug if you have advanced
lung cancer oh my God it's like can't we
have a drug for people who have just a
little bit of lung cancer yeah whatever
it's like why do I have to have like
Advanced lung cancer but that's that's
who that you know that's the audience
and and you know people Fox you know fox
has the biggest audience they also have
the oldest audience and
um you know the and but but across the
board the ads are for
um
um you know of pharmaceuticals because
that's I want to show something Rob I'm
going to show this to you because the
point you're making right now so do you
know the patent laws and Drugs in
America do you know that patent law so
so the patent laws in America uh
pharmaceutical companies get 12 years
guaranteed Market Market exclusivity for
biologists and 20 years for each patent
okay so you know it used to be 12 they
raise it to 20.
the a senator and a congressman from the
left and the right agreed to say let's
lower to 12. this is not cool and then
eventually they brought it back up I'm
going to send you these two things so
two of the most popular drugs that we
take in America one of them is
um listen excuse my English being my
fifth language Lipitor am I saying
Liberator okay all right so Lipitor Rob
I'm gonna send this to your map I take
it myself
Rob if you can receive it and pull it up
when you see this on what happens the
year the patterns go away okay so check
this out if you can show this uh uh uh
Rob did you get it or no okay I would I
would run on this and I would show this
because this whole concept of
advertising Pharma and US losing these
people because they're getting paid
behind closed doors there's loyalty to
whoever helps pay your bills there's a
loyalty to whoever's The Advertiser for
the most time watch this for the most
part
Rob do you have them
okay so okay there you go so if you see
the drop-off of these two numbers the
year the patent is over with so it's
showing what it's selling for and how
much the patent expires if if I but if
before we even look at the zoom in a
little bit can you zoom in a little bit
generic yeah yeah so this is Lipitor
okay zoom in and go up a little bit the
other way so we can see the bottom
numbers okay so check this out look at
that how high it is okay uh it's going
uh one and a half billion to see the
chart yep so all the way at the top look
what kind of numbers they're doing 12
billion is the top 12 billion 2012 is
when the patent expires look how low it
goes from doing 12 billion at its peak
to 76 million dollars go to the next one
this is Lipitor now let's do the next
one here which is for
a drug for bipolar and uh schizo look at
this one here five point six to eight
billion Peak 2011 it expires look how
quickly it drops and look how much it's
worth in 2021.
92 million versus 5.2 billion in
revenues from One Drug okay so this is
the part where Americans are like dude
so really it didn't really cost you this
much to make it no bro it's like Pennies
on a dollar but we charge you 600 bucks
damn there's a part of this where I'm
like look you know I don't mind giving
you a a a pattern you ought to get it
because we want innovation in in this
space no questionable like listen cancer
we got a cure and there's respect to a
lot of advancement that we have made we
have to salute 100 my dad's 81 years old
he should have been there not 65 years
old Ken golden who is one of the
original guys from uh
from uh Home Depot billionaire 45
Billion Auto guy
he had a phenomenal debate with
Elizabeth Warren two three years ago he
said my dad died at 62 years old he's
saying this in his book I love
capitalism he said but if my dad would
have been born 20 years later when they
invented blood thinners my dad would
have lived in his 80s he says because
I've been on blood thinner since I was
60 years old and he's now 83 84 years
old so what an interesting testimony so
we want the Innovation but guess what 20
years patent I don't know about that how
about we lower it to five years and then
five years later the person that came up
with the patent you get to sell it to
other people and whatever they sell 50
comes to you which means you release the
patent that there's still some kind of
profits coming back to you I think this
is another thing that's going to force
big Pharma to be more honest if we
eliminate advertising and if we minimize
the patent from 20 years to five years
it becomes a little bit more competitive
you make a great great point we have
Medicare and Social Security which is a
safety net originally designed as a
safety net to help the elderly so there
is a very real spreadsheet that goes on
in Medicare to getting life-saving drugs
life-extending drugs to these people and
it is kind of funked up that the drug
companies have less of a copyright or
patent than Mickey Mouse a couple years
ago you read about how hard Disney was
working to protect the image of Mickey
Mouse because of its commercial value
and the branding value to Disney so why
does why do we have those things which
argue that hey it was built by a company
it's entertained by people you can do it
but it's not necessarily as critical as
other drugs are and I think I think what
you're bringing up Pat is instead of
opening the floodgates to the generics
because they always talk about the
Canadian generics when you if you go
deep into the Medicare discussion you go
straight to the Canadian Church yeah 24
months 24 months after the expiration
hey why can't we buy the Canadian
generics for our older people to say hey
you can still get your Lipitor but
you'll just get the Canadian generics
it's a lot less because the patent's
something that we can get over here
why not make the licensing option of it
take away the advertising and provide a
longer term licensing option at the same
time finding ways to you know make the
the drugs themselves more affordable
because we can all scream about the
costs and everything but there's a
couple realities the competitive set
United States is resulting in these
drugs these drugs are not being invented
around the world and this is the reason
that John Hopkins you've got and you
know about this you're familiar
Washington you've got entire floors that
John Hopkins have special security
because foreign dignitaries are coming
here for Advanced Health Care Services
why is that because the competitive set
of capitalism and things and for
Enterprise in America are resulting in
in competing to make medical instruments
and stuff so the right thing is happens
that competition is resulting in great
things but then long term we need to get
the cost under control and and you take
away the advertising and Pat you're
right you put licensing on it and you
will take five steps in a direction hey
if you enjoyed this short Club you want
to watch the whole thing click over here
but if you want to make 2023 the
beginning of the greatest years of your
life I host a conference once year it's
called The Vault conference where 3 000
CEOs executive entrepreneurs from around
the world come together to strategize
for three and a half days this year it's
going to be at Miami Diplomat Resort and
the speakers this year is going to be
Tom Brady he'll be they'll be
interviewing them Mike Tyson will gudara
the guy that ran 11 Madison in New York
if you run a business if you're a CEO
entrepreneur and executive this is not
an event you want to miss out on get
yourself your spouse your business
partner your running mates registered
and I look forward to seeing you there
click on the link here or see the link
in the description and I hope to spend
three and a half days with you in Miami
in August and September take care
everybody
thank you